yeah make your own really join my
[ __ ] religion well but haha well
you're do why because i'm already okay
so i'm already okay so nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope
next one
hey chris and matt my name is jason i'm
27 currently a student at san francisco
state university
um i'm on campus a lot walking around
and uh i get approached by
a christian group who is trying to like
recruit me or something and keep asking
me someone still turned the bible study
and uh you know i've been polite to say
no thank you i'm not interested but uh
i've been kind of
wanting to respond in a funnier way and
maybe tell them that i'm i can't make it
because i'm
on my way to a blood sacrifice to
worship satan or just maybe just reply
hail satan and walk away right
you know but i don't know if that'd be
appropriate or polite you know
anyways i just want to know what you
guys would do would you continue trying
to be polite it happens like every time
i'm on campus and it's really nice
or would you you know respond with some
comedy and just do something that makes
makes you laugh they probably wouldn't
laugh they'd probably be upset about it
so that would be nice but
it'd be funny
anyways just thought i'd throw that out
there appreciate you guys love the work
you do keep it up thanks what's up with
uh he goes to a like a religious school
is that what it is i don't think that's
what he said no oh then that's even more
annoying yeah they're just there i think
he's at a school because it's like prime
candidates young vulnerable people just
like cult yes dude but i think uh the
thing to do to save yourself time but
also get that sort of like
comedy thing that at least what what
being funny provides you can still get
the same thing if like say they approach
you and you know they're coming you know
what they're gonna say just keep walking
but as you keep walking just say nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope it's a
very mad thing to do yeah or be like how
about you don't be religious you join my
side right yeah hey here's a no make
pamphlets that's a good idea not not
religious this like you know what i mean
yeah like you make up your own religion
or you know the non-religion
here you go join my [ __ ] religion
yeah yeah make your own really join my
[ __ ] religion well but
well you're do why because i'm already
well okay so i'm already okay so didn't
say any nouns we're both already didn't
say any nouns you know i mean but that's
so annoying i mean that's the most
annoying thing yeah
i'm glad you asked dude i've been
wanting to talk to you about the church
of guy who touches his hat too much
yeah that's who he was yeah would you
like a would you like a ball cap yeah
yeah you know how jews wear yarmulkes
brought it up twice maybe chris chris
and matt's grandma was jewish we don't
know because she was adopted brought up
three times
um
yeah i think you can look they're
approaching you about their religion
religion at least used to be one of the
most private things in the [ __ ] world
now people talk about their religion and
politics like it's their [ __ ]
favorite kind of juice or meal lunchtime
when did religion be when was it the
most private thing in the world though
because
two things you don't ask about was was
your religion and your politics when i
don't mean like [ __ ] 1400s because in
the 1400s this [ __ ] was really really
prevalent and everyone knew who everyone
was because everyone was one thing or
else you would be killed dead or you'd
either basically be wearing crosses or
have no head right so they'd be like oh
you've got a cross or you're catholic or
you're christian or oh that guy's got no
head so he must have been a jew or
something or something yeah yeah
uh well luckily we don't live then but
no i mean like in the 50s and before
like right it was impolite the 1950s i
assume
you would get an answer when you ask
somebody what their [ __ ] religious
beliefs were and there's something to
that it's it's like
it's it seems so bold to be like to
expect other people to openly talk about
the religion or politics for that matter
yeah but you know i think you can so
they come up to you politely but what
they're doing is rude yeah so you can be
as rude as you want it doesn't matter
how like polite they come yeah the thing
it's like being nice when you're
stabbing someone you're still stabbing
them so when
but yeah be as rude as you want nice to
meet you and being rude to someone like
that is funny so you get a little bit of
a dummy double whammy um oh oh here's
another good one hey uh i'd like to talk
to you about it to try and convert you
to my religion oh
oh are we gonna [ __ ] whoa
that seems okay keep going
we're getting married oh my god okay are
we getting oh
dude right we're getting married right
and then they say no you say then what
the [ __ ] does my religion have to do
with you okay it's a bit of a stretch
but i still like what you're doing spin
around and then you show them that spin
move mentality hoodie knew that was
coming well we're predictable but mostly
it's it's good that we have the spin
move now
people can get the hoodie to have the
the words on their body
backing up that's right coinciding with
the action that's great
i never really realized that have you
ever by design baby
i'm very creative
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]